vamos a analizar otra prueba de
convergencia que es la prueba de series
alternantes y voy a ir explicando esta
prueba al mismo tiempo que la aplico a
una serie real para que la explicación
de esta prueba sea un poco más concreta
tenemos esta serie infinita que va desde
n igual acá hasta infinito de atsur n
podemos definir a sub n como menos 1 a
la n por b sub n o la podemos definir a
sub n como menos 1 a la n 1 por b sub n
donde ve su n es mayor o igual a 0 para
todas las en es que nos interesan es
decir para todos los enteros que sean
iguales o mayores acá todo esto se
cumple y además conocemos estas dos
cosas el límite cuando n tiende a
infinito debe psuv n es igual a 0 y que
b sub n es una sucesión decreciente lo
que nos dice que la serie infinita
original converge esto puede parecer
algo abstracto así que vamos a aplicar
esto con una serie real para que nos
quede más claro tenemos la serie que va
desde n igual a 1 hasta
de menos 1 a la n 1 / n podemos
desarrollar esta serie para que sea más
clara para n igual a 1 esto es menos 1
al cuadrado entre 1 que es igual a 1
para n igualados esto es menos 1 a la
tercera potencia entre 2 que es menos un
medio más un tercio menos un cuarto y
continúa así hasta la eternidad podemos
reescribir esta suv n de esta forma
claro que sí de hecho aquí está el menos
1 a la n 1 de forma explícita podemos
reescribir ésta a su vez n que es menos
1 a la n 1 entre n como menos 1 a la n 1
por 1 entre n y podemos decir que esta
parte es bs n podemos verificar que esta
vez sub n es mayor o igual a 0 para
todos los valores de n que nos interesan
b sub n será igual o mayor a 0 para
cualquier n positiva cuál es el límite
debe suben cuando n tiende a infinito
límite de 1 / n cuando n tiende a
infinito es igual a 0 se satisface la
primera restricción y vemos que esta es
una sucesión decreciente pues conforme n
incrementa el denominador incrementa y
si hay un denominador más grande el
valor de la división va a disminuir por
lo que podemos afirmar que uno entre n
es una sucesión decreciente para los
valores de n que nos interesan esto
satisface la segunda restricción con
base en que ve sub
n es mayor o igual a 0 su límite cuando
n tiende a infinito es 0 y eso también
es una sucesión decreciente entonces
podemos afirmar que la serie original
converge la escribimos la suma desde n
igual a 1 hasta infinito de menos 1 a la
n 1 entre n esto es interesante porque
ya vimos que si todos estos términos
fueran positivos tendríamos la serie
armónica la cual no convergen pero estas
series y converge debido a estos
términos negativos de hecho podemos
demostrar que esta serie converge
aplicando otras técnicas en particular
la prueba de comparación de límites
mencionó esto
en curiosidad de investigar más al
respecto esta es una herramienta
poderosa que se parece un poco a la
prueba de divergencia pero recuerden que
la prueba de divergencia sólo sirve si
queremos demostrar que una serie es
divergente si el límite de los términos
no se aproxima a cero entonces esa serie
va a divergir esto es útil porque
demuestra convergencia y de nuevo si
algo no pasa la prueba de alternancia no
significa necesariamente que es
divergente simplemente significa que no
podemos usar la prueba de alternancia
para demostrar que convergen nos vemos
en el siguiente vídeo